Trump has no incentive to debate right
now I've got the real clear politics
average of polling Trump is up according
to the RCP average Trump is up
32.4 points oh that's a big number now
the RCP average is a very reliable
fairly conservative average of polls
that includes morning consult Economist
you got Fox Emerson NBC Yahoo Harvard
Harris CNN the messenger Harris Expo
we've got all of them there Trump is
crushing the field 32.4 is the average
Harvard Harris has him up 45 points over
the rest of the field this is a 10
person field it's not even close with a
commanding lead like that that he does
not appear to be losing in fact his lead
only appears to either remain the same
or to be increasing as his most intense
primary Challenger seems to be losing
ground why on Earth would Trump get on
that stage